his name is bounced around a little bit  possible florida state  off the inbounds the alley-oop and that  works to their  probably top nba prospect devon vasel  comes on the screen right around the  i mean screen got to step out and close  that laying off i mean you can't let him  go to the goal  sharing the ball hoover without the ball  making shots he follows it oh  and he gets it to go devin the  [Applause]  that was a terrific fast break  transition maybe  they have something a little more  special on their hands maybe you can put  those conversations to bed  simply because how they won in those  seven games again  three post position right there to  demand the basketball  backfire with the arm balls there are no  good turnovers  from the corner the three is good